I felt sorry for that dude but you know
where you gonna do I had to lay that
damn what then lay you down hey but I
don't fight you was that it got a couple
licks in sure but I was like man I put
the [ __ ] on [ __ ] on the chain wax
hmm is that a thing
well yeah yeah that's the thing okay
[Applause]
I just googled [ __ ] on the chain wax no
results me um why are you googling no
I'm just saying [ __ ] on the chain wax
it's not an expression
Thank You leo
yeah what does it mean then what does it
mean I'll tell you what it means you
know it loans that is that you put the
[ __ ]
[Applause]
okay have either the two of you have you
ever said the words [ __ ] on the chain
wax in any context he told me you me me
hey man it's not our fault that you
ain't never put backs
cuz [ __ ] on the chain wax ain't a thing
you trying to start a thing aren't you
well I mean what are you talking about
trying to start a thing a thing like off
the hook or I'm gonna put you on blast
you tryin get it in the ether so
everybody out there saying [ __ ] on the
chain wax me why are you doing this why
looking at I'm saying
and in fact checking my ass you keep
saying some that doesn't exist and you
got thing one and thing two
corroborating your story like it does
and why you lying there it's base Bodie
[Music]
why do you care so much whether I made
up [ __ ] on the chain wax or not I lost
my job no girl left and all I wanted to
do was have a little bit of fun with my
friends today so why do you have why do
you have to belittle me like that
[Music]
it's just that idea
I'm just trying to say try to say I'm
trying to say that I want to put the
[ __ ]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
you